hello and welcome to this rapid game wow
that's a huge reading to Santa some this
I cannot pronounce at a difference oh
he's playing the dumb yellow defense
with f6 um yeah I think one should take
right okay check that should win for
white check Bishop c4 check check yeah
now King g6 I guess no flicks that in
okay so Bishop t5ho check but how to win
after after this Oh to win here is it h4
h4 h5 it looks pretty awful
h4 h5 bishop jakes b 7 is a funky idea
yeah but h4 must be right so let's do
this or let's let's think for a moment
down
and yeah I think it should be right the
yeah so here I can check on g three
years one idea
there's also Bishop takes b7 as a move
Bishop e7 Bishop takes b7 Queen f5
checking age 6 d for check and wins the
house if I take on b7 he has special d6
however
that's not so convincing um what else
I've got f4 f5
also quite good I guess checking on g3
kh7 doesn't look so convincing if I just
go to form now Bishop t6 and the game
continues
a4 not f6f five king x outlets not that
clear actually the a bishop takes b7
looks looks nice but can he defend
bishop t6 that's what a weird move
it should be 76
hmm yeah it's not convincing not so
convincing taking one GH is entirely
pointless I guess
d for Bishop d6 is actually quite
embarrassing so
hmm that's not so clear I mean it should
be something but I don't see it at the
moon Bishop e7 should be six
23 king at seven Bishop f7 that doesn't
help really not okay can I just play for
an attack without looking for a direct
win that's not so easy let's go to ship
you sex with d66 cd6 with tempo there
should be seven let's check this again
there should be seven bishop t6 yeah
maybe I just have to do this i mean i
can't play a queen should be five for
example it just felt like i should have
something better okay i just hope he
doesn't just take it yeah and all my
calculation here was for naught yeah
bishop d6 i have no checks no meaningful
ones Queen B 5 and then c 6 or 8 6 i go
queen bee three and I've got four points
then and still the bad King position
hmm probably I didn't exploit this to
the exploit this to fullest I don't know
oh come on check
black resigns ya know is in d4 check
okay so it's actually rather interesting
to have this on video once the f6 move
it's a well-known mistake in this
position that can be exploited with the
number of ways why does not necessarily
have to take only five even though it is
the most forceful move white also has a
better position after D for Bishop c4
the reason why it's not super clear this
is the best movies that here a black is
able to if he's not taking yeah he can
continue the game with a bad position
something like this for example check
and it's not clear if this is better
than let's say the immediate like and
six Bishop c4 or deform what is well
known whether is that the capture should
lose so let's see justice yes this the
chance right okay and now let's see what
the engine says okay the engine wants to
play exactly my line h4 h5 and B should
be seven so okay I'm so I didn't do
anything wrong but I wasn't i was a bit
irritated here that there wasn't
anything better than Bishop d7 I think
I've seen this motif before but yeah I
wanted to check if there is something
some made or so but there isn't deform
should be six is not cleared all for
example 1 F form that could even
backfire on me I think here ok there's
Queen g5 but this is possible check and
white also has exposed his own position
quite a bit so this is the winner
it was a stylist okay but yeah i was
thinking Bishop t6 and then okay the
engine wants to go to a five and this is
a good move of course black still cannot
take I was thinking here just cover but
c6 queen bee three here this is still
yeah this is still continuing and not
entirely clear I've got how many points
five points for the piece but position
is kind of murky this is even better
though because black cannot take and he
has no temple now on the Queen so I'm
just winning the Rookie in the corner or
some other huge material like knight c6
Bishop c6 will be aid yeah and the way
it went I shall check and after King
here go default check and now the bishop
is the decisive piece g5 is not when you
move check and this now wins quite
easily takes check check check check
something like that is a disaster for
black so whatever you do don't play f6
or move to yeah this is just a bad
decision it even has a name the damn
Yahoo defense as Damiano I think he's
from this see from the 16th century yeah
like one of the earliest erm chess
analysts back then even they recognized
that this is not a good idea okay well
thanks for watching